right now waiting to learn whether there
will be a Senate hearing next week over
a sexual assault allegation against the
president's Supreme Court nominee
remember that story it's a big one today
still developing at this hour
negotiations are said to be ongoing with
the lawyer for the accuser Christine
Blasi Ford this morning's original
deadline of 10:00 a.m. has become the
end of the day today 10 p.m. were
hearing she has agreed to talk under
some pretty unusual conditions meanwhile
President Trump is calling out Christine
Blasi Ford by name for the first time
chief congressional correspondent
Michael mango on Capitol Hill were where
things stand at this moment it's been
changing throughout the day good evening
Mike no doubt Brett good evening to you
a senior Republican source tells FOX
details are coming soon a bit of a tease
there this as the Senate Judiciary
Committee is awaiting a response from
Christine Blasi Ford about whether she
will show up for a hearing on Wednesday
either way the president and the Senate
Majority Leader are signaling they won't
let this drag out but here's what I want
to tell you in the very near future
judge Kavanagh will be on the United
States Supreme Court Majority Leader
Mitch McConnell tried to reassure
conservatives at the end of it all
they'll have the votes a 10 a.m.
deadline came and went but the
negotiations continued Ford's legal team
wanted a Thursday hearing with Kavanaugh
testifying first and judiciary members
not outside attorneys asking questions
committee sources say Cavanaugh first
and the demand that the committee
subpoena Cavanaugh classmates are
non-starters judiciary Republicans
countered with a Wednesday hearing with
a female attorney doing the questioning
of both and that Ford would go first
president Trump signaled last night he's
running out of patience to take a man
like this and be spurts now with that
being said
have her say and let's see how it all
works out but I don't think you can
delay it any longer than today on
Twitter the president wrote asking to
see police reports I have no doubt that
if the attack on dr. Ford was as bad as
she says charges would have been
immediately filed with local law
enforcement authorities by either her or
her loving parents I asked that she
bring those filings forward so we can
learn date time and place I was appalled
by the president's tweet I thought that
the president's tweet was completely
inappropriate and wrong Collins a key
GOP swing senator says she's fine having
hearings delayed a couple of days former
Vice President Joe Biden a former
Judiciary Chairman said there should not
be a vote if professor Ford decides
against testifying she should not have
to go through what it needed Hill went
through and some of the questions she
got asked and the end and the way the
right went after her a national
television then questioned her integrity
questions her not just their honesty
questioned her behavior and the
California congresswoman who professor
Ford first approached was asked if she
has regrets about the way Democrats
handled her situation I felt offended
for her that that there that there were
leaks when she decided to speak publicly
I was proud of her
another critical Republican senator is
Alaska's Lisa Murkowski who is under
tremendous pressure from outside groups
to vote no she has been very very quiet
in recent days Brett okay we'll come
back from breaking details Mike thank
you